ladies and gentlemen welcome to screen
junkies movie fights powered by the
popcorn Talk network now your host Andy
signor uhoh it's already beginning
welcome to movie fights guys guys guys
guys guys calm down this is going to be
a good one I can tell just by the
fighting already welcome to movie fights
uh uh so happy to be here we have so
many exciting guests and so much
exciting stuff to talk about uh
including we are we didn't really want
to tackle it but so many people have
asked us the interview should have been
canceled we're going to break it down
what video game movie uh should be made
since we have a a fantastic video game
expert here I'll introduce in a minute
and best Ian McKellen movie another
really fun topic so lots of fun stuff as
always if you don't like what we're
talking about at a at a specific moment
click the bottom right if you're
watching on YouTube and you can pick
your fight and and zoom around to all
the battles that we have today uh also
before we start I want to also always
mention how grateful we are to be here
on The popcor Talk network very exciting
place to be uh so much fun content
they're doing please go check out
popcorn Talk network on the YouTube uh
and see see all their exciting movie
discussion shows we're happy to be part
of that family Maria manudos sosno thank
you guys uh please keep supporting them
um and also support us on iTunes because
if you unless you are listening to
iTunes well then awesome you're already
there uh but you can download us on
iTunes the podcast subscribe rate all
that jazz uh let's get to this fight all
right the Gladiators for today are here
to argue uh let's meet up first I'm so
happy to have them here from smos games
it's Jovenshire and so happy to be here
every day I get to talk about video
games but now I get to talk about my
other passion movies and superh and and
fun stuff like that yeah we somehow
managed to squeeze in some video game
stuff for you works for me next to him
he's back he's a fan favorite and some
not always but that's what I love about
it you love them you hate them it's
Roger bar that's right and uh I
apologize to you guys in advance because
there's probably going to be a lot of
nicked blood on you by the end of this
episode I'm in it's flash Zone it is
movie fights and next to him his arch
nemesis it's Nick Mundy the bad boy of
movie fights is back fight Monday fight
fight Monday fight it's Monday die was
the was the cage we had you in uh
comfortable all these weeks yeah I was
busy the one you've been dodging me in
yeah oh I'm I'm here every day sleeping
on that couch I have nowhere else to go
we're happy to have you back Nick and
we're and we figured if we're going to
bring you back let's bring the guy who
brought the most passion against you
last time oh we got some over the top
action going here I was going last catch
him over the top better and as always on
the couch factchecking us to make sure
we are correct it's Dan Merl on The Dan
cam hi how's it going Dan enough how's
the Dan cam feeling today I'm I'm worn
out over still from last night's Epico
battle Yeah we pre-taped this and last
night was our live schmoeville if you
didn't see it go check out shimo no
podcast we did a live movie fight with
this fellow that fellow how R Nick we
beat the crap screen for shim spoiler
alert we just beat them but I think it
was a fair fight I I do think I judged
fairly uh all right well let's quit
talking about ourselves and let's get to
these battles in the great words of Ken
Wabi Let Them Fight
what was that I didn't I didn't catch
that he's very quiet it was a mediocre
important all right uh this is a
controversial one and I I want to be
careful because this isn't a politics
show that's what's fun about this show
is it's a movie Dumb movie show but
there it's a big issue and so many
people are talking about us on Twitter I
thought we have to at least discuss it
uh round one why so serious one of
hundreds of who asked on Twitter do you
agree or disagree with Sony's decision
to cancel the interview uh so obviously
if you've lived under a rock you you uh
would know the story but Sony had this
movie the interview where Seth Rogan
James Franco stupid comedy you know
stupid it's a mean word silly comedy uh
where they are then interviewing Kim
Jong-un and they uh the government says
why don't you go get him kill them while
you're there it's clearly a silly comedy
but North Korea was upset Sony hackers
were upset everyone got hacked at Sony
and then now threatening we're going to
blow up a theater or do something crazy
if you show the movie The theaters back
down uh and said we wouldn't show the
movie which then prompted Sony to
finally have an out and say well we're
not releasing the movie and now they've
said they're not releasing it anywhere
not on VOD not on anything nothing so it
brings up the question is this was this
uh was this a good decision do we want
to still see the interview would we have
gone to see the interview maybe it's
another good question to ask uh let's
start with you Joven Shire uh I'm going
to say yes uh it was a smart decision
that they didn't release it uh I think
there's a lot going on behind the scenes
that maybe just everyone's not aware of
seeing how even if the smallest incident
would have occurred where hell if
someone had tripped up the stairs in the
theater falling down and broken their
ankle uh the story would be completely
different people wouldn't be complaining
about oh let them release the movie it'
been like oh man look how greedy Sony is
they're just looking for a dollar uh
that they'll use all this publicity just
to make that dollar back and then now
they're backing up and they're saying no
we aren't going to release it I think
for them in the long run is a better uh
is a better play on on their end I think
that they can make the money back fact
that they've lost on the production of
this movie plus you just have to look at
risk risk assessment is it worth it it's
absolutely not worth it if if just the
smallest incident could have happened
from this whether it be something
something small like more leaks from
from Sony or something big like any kind
of attack like it's just not worth it
Roger um I also think it was a good
decision uh I think Sony was in kind of
a lose lose situation here either way
honestly um you know whether it got
released in theaters or if they choose
not to uh people are going to be
complaining about it one way or the
other whether anything happened in the
theaters or not um I also the real
reason I I think it's a good thing is
because now everybody will not have to
spend $20 on Seth Rogan uh fumbling
through another movie I don't I don't
care about it I don't care about it I
don't want to see Seth Rogan uh doing
his is he laughing is he coughing I
don't know I don't give a [__] I don't
want to I don't want to see that nope
nope no that is like the least like of
the concerns Nick what your Korea could
have been pissed off at Annie and I
would be the first person to see Annie
if they threaten to like do something to
take us away from seeing it this is all
about freedom of speech and you're
talking about risk assessment and money
it's not about money it's about like
freedom of speech and that that's what
this country is built on and like look
we they made a stupid movie that's okay
like you can go see it or not I would
choose to see it just to like give them
big middle finger be realistic real
istic everyone is still anyone who wants
to see will be able to find it on the
internet now they just won't have to pay
for it which is awful which is awful
because hold on that's not true the
according to the new from the Guardians
Of Peace they're like well now you never
can release this movie it can never see
the light of day we aren't leaking it
now they've also said we're not leaking
more Sony items so and it's already
creating a slippery slope because
Paramount pull Team America from
screenings that the like other theaters
were doing so anyone complains about a
movie cuz it hurts their feelings like
you know like like you complain about
fast this is great I'm going to I'm
going to write North Korea and say hey I
heard they said something bad about
North Koreans in Fast and the Furious
and it's canel well you know I want that
that's great they just set the president
they just set the presid you really want
that Roger come on and it's a and it's a
bad situation and look look I get it
what if they said Interstellar is
against North Korea I already saw it I'm
okay with it Christopher Nolan's next
movie that's the best best movies ever
made I get your point and I see your
point set up a theater hire security
charge $50 for the tickets do that I
don't care to pay for the security but I
want to go see it as a like interesting
yeah would you have wanted to see this
movie if it wasn't for all the
controversy though that is I yes I would
cuz I see stupid comedies all the time
I'm on I do a show called movie fights I
need to see stupid crap all the time
that's the thing that I hate about this
whole situation though I mean it's it no
one really cared that much about this
movie when it was announced that doesn't
matter if they were talking about Annie
I would be the first person to see Annie
because someone's saying I can't do
something and like this is what our
country was built upon let's step back
it's a good question I want to ask each
of you would you have seen this movie
without the controversy no no yes would
you have seen the movie hence the
controversy and for the fu to the
terrorists and they decided to release
it in a theater might you have changed
your mind and supported that I would
have been swayed to yes Roger I I still
wouldn't pay to see the movie I just
don't care about it and you know I don't
think it's it's this big Fu to the
terrorists I don't and I I totally agree
you know like you know Sony uh you know
or it was actually theaters who decided
not to run the movie yeah they're the
biggest cowards they're the biggest
they're the ones who who who did that
but you know it's it's you know just
like a bomb threat being called into a
building and stuff you know I I guess
they're just taking it seriously in that
way ask me the question so with an
American flag Cape you know and face
paint I would be that guy Dan would you
have gone to see the
movie I I would have gotten to see it uh
I was pre controversial seeing it anyway
if they put it out I definitely would
have gone to see it but there was a new
message this morning from the the
hackers they said they demanded that
everything related to the movie
including the trailer be pulled from
every website that and they also
demanded that it never Nick will you let
me finish they've also demanded that it
will never come out on DVD pay-per-view
or video on demand and that the trailer
and any related material be pulled from
every website or they will we cond with
this one no
no and I I still I I don't think there's
any way that this is not going to end up
on the internet and being released
eventually one way or so is that the
answer is that the S I mean and I I'm I
wrap this up cuz I don't want it to be a
heated political debate cuz it could get
there but I almost feel like you gave
the best suggestion put it in a theater
charge $100 it's highly secure do we are
we against that scenario if if they're
going to put it in the theaters they
should you know raise it you know have
all the proceeds for it go to some
Charities or something like that how
about that yeah I mean do we like the
idea or just hey release it free online
it's now available to anyone who wants
to see it and there we're not making
they should put it in they should find a
theater with the balls to do it and they
put it in the theater and charge people
to do it like we would normally do I
don't want
to I want it in theaters right now I
want in a stadium it wasn't just
theaters that were being threatened
though uh employees at Sony not even
higher ups employees were being my
social security number is all over there
like so I get it but I don't care like
look this is going to happen like if we
do this then anyone's if someone like
Roger it's probably going to be Roger
gets pissed off at Fast and the Furious
someone makes a complaint they're going
to do it Paramount's already pulling
movies I North Korea likes Roger in this
why was World Police even back in
theaters to protest this whole thing
which is a dumb protest that's a
different argument but that's they put
it back and they're scared to but like I
just I just wish this was over a more
important movie like I wish this was why
did it have to be a a Seth Rogen James
Franco movie that this is this that
we're all having this huge discussion I
mean isn't that kind of the perfect
movie it really does prove because if
this was Oscar it shows how ridiculous
this is it absolutely does to be fair so
had the same problem with Dark 30 if I
remember right they had a lot of heat
and there was a lot of pressure on that
one to release that from the government
everything else and they stuck to their
guns and they released that John Stewart
was saying just the other night like his
movie didn't like raise any controversy
you know all the stuff in Iran and
everything uh so it's just like why I
think this just sets a dangerous
precedent and like anyone I mean I could
go into details about the groups but
like anyone could be like do we think
the government the multip the studios
did they handle it right no Roger Jo I I
think they did I think that this uh like
Roger was even touching on is the least
um they're going to it's a lose lose
situation this has the least
repercussions for him and the least
Collateral Damage I I I think Sony basic
if if they released it I I agree people
would have been saying you know they
were being greedy uh they were they they
would have been criticized even if
nothing happened in those theaters and
stuff people would have just been saying
they're taking risk with fans lives and
I mean that's not on Sony totally that's
on the theaters as well but regard Sony
would is getting the brunt of it yeah
this isn't the end all Beall of like oh
my God we've lost to the terrorist it
it's it's uh literally like okay they
won this battle we can still win the war
if you will like this one small Studio
except no studio will ever make a risky
movie again especially a risky it seems
like you're making a fact off of a
situation that hasn't happened yet you
guys also hear they already Steve
Carell's North Korean movie they did
they did it's already happening and like
Clooney so he wanted to get like
everyone to sign this thing saying
they'll stand together and no one signed
it which surprised the hell out of me
are I say let things calm down a little
bit and then we can start looking at
Steve's movie again we can look at hey
let's do a sequel to World Police now
like just tensions are a little high
right now or we throw up middle fingers
and play the movie everywhere like play
in Yankee Stadium play I mean like get
security I will charge me $500 for a
personal security guard I want to see it
I'm a stupid americ why don't we just
bomb North Korea with bombs filled with
copies of the movie well it's actually
uh South Korea I was reading is planning
to do that they of course they have a
copy of it somehow and they're planning
on sending balloons across across the
DMZ to North Korea so that the movie
Will by the way ironically North Korea
will be the only country that sees this
movie by the way and this should just be
pointed out I want to see the movie bad
now because of all the situation that
doesn't mean I will pirate it do not
pirate the movie do not steal it good
note and on top of that note I'm going
to give it to Nick I think Nick had the
best suggestion in that I like the idea
of let's if it's two theaters around the
country and we overcharge it for safe
security we it's a way to sort meet Both
Worlds it's the best option I've heard
and I feel like we can't let them scarce
to not have art that's what the the our
country is about and it does create a SI
St I think George Cooney did you call
the art it's thank you because that is a
real insult to Art it really is that's a
low blow I haven't seen the movie you
said it was a stupid movie and then you
corrected yourself and say it's silly no
it is a stupid movie and we know has
nothing to do it's a bigger issue than
that and I think what you brought up
with Clooney is a good point of like the
studios didn't handle it well they all
have competing movies coming out in
Christmas they're thinking about oh well
if that movie's gone I'm going to make
more money get hacked and then so I
think we could have United together
stronger in in such a serious issue that
I think I I give it to Nick you're a
little drastic but I think you made some
good suggestions so Nick good job point
to Nick right off the wow is that is
that the first time I've ever given you
a point in round one good for you man
yeah usually usually I'm going half
asleep with this all right round
two now the politics are gone good
very uh I have to figure out a way weird
segue to this yeah let's transition uh
so here's get the SES out get thees out
Stu that doesn't matter so uh completely
unrelated to that uh I mean this movie
is not going to make much money right
the interview because they're clearly
going to lose money on it so Major's
cats on Twitter asked best movie that
bombed at the box office what is the
movie that was actually pretty decent
that went to that had an unfortunate
timing whatever it was and did not make
a single dollar that and was actually
Justified and should have none of you
picked it but to me I think this year
probably the best one about was Edge of
Tomorrow where it's like pretty good
movie no one saw it let's go back even
further kill die death sorry yeah Live
Die Repeat now um which everyone should
go check out that movie it's a very it
was actually a very fun different
creative movie that no one just they
thought oh Tom Cruz movie I don't care
but they should have cared it was a
really fun different is amazing original
movies we should support those but
anyway let's beside that Roger all time
best movie that uh you know didn't get
the the service it should have I mean I
think the obvious answer would be sha
Shank Redemption because it did not do
well in theaters but my my personal pick
is Big Trouble in Little China and uh
this was a movie that John Carpenter had
high hopes for uh it it just did not do
well it made about 11 million in
theaters and it had a $20 million budget
um and since then it's it's generated a
huge cult following everybody loves the
movie uh it's got one of the greatest
lead characters who is actually supposed
to be a sidekick if you've heard John
Carpenter talk about it Jack Burton is
actually the sidekick in the movie and
Wang is actually the hero really uh and
he's just this fumbling All American
wonderful character abely hilarious yes
yes he would have absolutely that could
be Big Trouble in Little China too um uh
it's got amazing characters it inspired
Mortal Kombat uh I I mean there's
there's so much that uh that has come
out of big trouble little China and
we've not given it the the credit it
deserves uh uh back in the day
unfortunately next
uh I love big trouble little China too
uh I also love a movie wa you guys agree
on something yeah no that oh that's
cute you sorry let me my keep going uh
my favorite uh box office bomb is the uh
Iron Giant uh came out 1998 is9 it
didn't really have a theater release so
it's hard to tell Vin Diesel's big movie
probably the movie that got him to play
Groot more than any other movie before
cuz he's he's amazing in it and it's
just this great movie and the thing
about the movie is is if it had a Pixar
or a Disney logo in front of it it would
have made like $5 billion we'd have been
having the Iron Giant 3 it's just
terrible terrible marketing it still
really hasn't made a lot of money but
like honestly Disney should buy it and
then put it out and it would make a
couple of billion dollars unless someone
got upset about it Nick it I mean it it
came out in first of all it came out in
1999 it came out in 2000 theaters so it
had a it had a release it but do any
business no yeah definitely and like big
trouble little China had it release too
I mean like they these movies can have
releases but like think about a Pixar
movie even then had 4,000 theaters like
3,000 theaters 199 this is 1999 well how
many did Star Wars have a new Phantom
Menace I mean that was like I'll check
yeah I mean there I think it's a great
kids movie it that doesn't also Pander
to kids it is a great kids mov and I
think we all would agree joov Shire your
pick um both good movies uh but I'm
going to go with a Superhero Movie that
that flopped pretty hard and people
still like to hate it but I'm going to
say Daredevil now Daredevil though a
little bit um different even uh even for
its time Wake Me Up Inside Daredevil if
you look at it as like frame by frame
like even a silly scene like the fight
in the playground looks like it would
have been done exactly how it was shown
in a comic book it was a true to Heart
comic book movie uh the casting was very
good on it uh Colin frell's take on
Bullseye was was different yet still
interesting
and I I feel like again like it was a
perfect adaptation for what the um for
what the comic book would have looked
like and it looked like that just in the
movie and being able to take a character
like Kingpin uh a prominently white
character uh and casting him as uh
Michael or casting Michael Clark Duncan
for Kingpin was a bit um if I might say
racy at the time but like a good
character Choice like he played Kingpin
better than I think anyone else could
have played Kingpin the the difference
between your movie and ours is ours are
good oh that's and that's why it bombed
because it's a badad movie Ben Affleck
he was not I'm sorry Ben Affleck versus
uh you know Kurt Russell
no I want I want you to go on record so
is Daredevil a good film I I think so I
I think uh if you don't look at it the
at the same bar that we put um other
superhero movies it was a great
superhero movie can I just chime in here
um yeah of course Dan go ahead first of
all Nick to to to button up that
question Star Wars Episode One open on
in 2,970 theaters I giant opened in
2,179 theaters so you know a few more
for Stars episode one Daredevil had a
production budget of 78 million and made
180 worldwide 100 million domestics so
do it's not as much of a bomb as as it's
a bomb because people ha it it but more
more importantly uh if you watch dared
it does not hold up I mean even even
putting aside that I don't think is a
good movie it it just does not hold up
how it looks and a Big Trouble in Little
China still looks awesome does it I love
it's F fill with neon it's filled with
neon it it is filled with ridiculous
lightning effects it has that amazing
fight scene in the
alleyway because it's a bad movie it's
not a bad movie it's a bad movie let
join reply it uh big Dr little chel is a
cult classic people love it because it's
it's bad it it's one of those things
that live up like a good bad horror
movie kind of kind of
situation it's not it's not a good bed
it's it's just awesome this is one of
the best movies
it's so entertain it's a movie that you
can watch countless times like if it
comes on TV you will watch it if it's a
rainy day that is like a perfect does it
have a blind man that saves the day and
gets the girl shut up man stop okay okay
so you're talking bad bad movies good
bad movies that's what they're saying
I'm talking about good good movie In The
Iron Giant it's just a really it's the
how much money did they lose on that Dan
so I was just looking this up so Iron
Giant had a production budget of $70
million and they also got Cal Arts
students to help with the movies
it made $23 million so they lost about
uh mil on that big trouble had a
production by you were right on Roger
actually it had a production budget of
20 mil it made 11.1 mil yil made money
also look at how much these movies have
made since their theatrical release um
your movie Iron Giant still hasn't made
back probably uh that much it's still a
bomb yeah I mean Parton me I can call I
let's move on to a more exciting battle
cuz I don't think this is that exciting
but look what the influence that big
trouble had that's where I'm to get I
feel like people still like big trouble
and it's gotten its just deserved we're
talking about a movie Giant still
doesn't get any deserves and it's like I
I just don't I don't know Daredevil to
me isn't a bomb if it did well and I
just you're not selling me a why was a
good movie but uh between big trouble
and Iron Giant aside from the fact that
Iron Giant really did lose the money I
think we could all agree people like Big
Trouble in Little China they know of it
they've watched it later whereas I still
feel like people don't under like still
still underestimated and haven't seen
the Iron Giant which is a great kids
movie that I think and your point of
Disney logo or Pixar movie in front of
it it would be a classic and it because
it didn't it bombed but you're talking
about you know movies movies that bombed
in the theater and stuff and that's
that's the key here I mean big trouble
didant bombed in the theater both of
them both of them bombed but which is
the your your question is what's the
best movie that bombed and Big Trouble
in Little China I well I'm basing the
best uh I'm giving iron joh a little bit
more credit just because I feel like
it's still deserve it's still bombing
and it deserves to not be bombed because
I think uh big so I'm calling it to Nick
again what is going on for the record I
agreeed everything said I agreeed
everything Roger
said what is
happening all right round
three uh The Hobbit franchise is over
some myself and would say okay good
let's have Peter Jackson do something
else uh wow that was long right I mean
that was a long experience anybody
disagree with me no I haven't seen yet
so they're long uh so that brings up the
question of they they had a movie
marathon of The Hobbit that people went
to I just don't know how they did it our
friend Deon C did I don't know how he
did it the original Lord of the Rings
too no I think it was just the three hot
movies but just that alone the idea that
feels like a really big chore uh Korea
can get mad about that it was homework
it was homework watching The Hobbit
movies was nerd homework so anyway it
brings up the question from uh on
Twitter from uh damed uh D ammed Hassan
uh who asks best movie marathon what is
that movie that we'd watch a series of
movies that we would watch back toback
and sit and actually want to do uh
probably in our underwear eat and ice
cream whatever it is uh what's that
movie let's start with you nick uh Rocky
the rocky franchise the story of America
um as he fights not only AP I thought it
was Die Hard uh story of America um the
thing about Rocky is it's it's really
one continuous story as he learned
learns to step up and fight Apollo and
then expectations of himself and then
finally Mr T and then finally communism
when he defeats ComEd uh yeah I know
music play it's got a great score it's
won uh some Oscars best movie and it is
the greatest movies ever made now I'm
talking about Rocky one through four and
then the end credits for five and then
Rocky baloa that is how you watch all
the Rockies all right ni you the watch
the end credit a little unfair vantage
with the music is now it really took me
there well he's moving moment he's the
senior panelist so I guess he get some
all right Jovin uh best best uh movie
marathon uh my favorite time of year to
Marathon movies is October with some
horror movies I'm a big zombie fan so I
like to look at uh some of the Romero's
Classics uh my order and versions of
movies that I watch is I start off with
Night of Living Dead the Remake then for
Don of the Dead I actually go to Zach
Snider's uh um remake of it and then you
have uh we go to the original of Day of
the Dead by Romero and then I personally
really enjoyed diary of the Dead uh the
first person shot zombie movie and then
end with um Land of the Dead because you
just can't go wrong with Luigi in a
zombie movie wow good interesting lineup
there Roger what's your call uh I also
love Halloween huge Halloween fan and uh
watching horror movies is absolutely the
way to go uh for me it's Friday the 13th
um several reasons uh first off all of
them huh all of them uh not the Remake
the not the Remake but you'd go through
Jason X and then frd vers let the H the
let the H the here here's the thing uh
there's enough of them that you can have
the marathon be as long as you want or
as short as you want um they span
several decades which is great uh
because you get this wide variety of
things the first one it's Jason's mom
doing it killing the second one you have
Jason alerts yes the second one you have
Jason wearing a sack on his head the
third one he has the hockey
mask in 3D and you have this this
evolution of Jason where like by the end
he's just like a crazed zombie who's
just absolutely Unstoppable early on
he's more killable but you also have
wait wait wait you also have some
amazing like early appearances by uh you
know uh people who are now famous Kevin
Bacon back in the early days getting
stabb through the throat you have
chrisen Glover doing one of the most
incredible dance scenes you will ever
see I mean it is amazing uh you have
Jason battling a girl you do that danene
huh oh God I wish you remind me of Chris
GL REM s that's the best compliment you
could give me if you win what about the
one time when you fought Freddy that was
really good oh God I love it okay here's
the thing about your movies uh my guy
could kick both of your guys all your
asses I don't know he's theing communism
I would watch that movie yeah I know I
want to go I want to push back a little
on Friday I'm not saying it's bad right
I'm just it becomes kind of comedic is
that fair to say oh absolutely like I
mean I mean let's think about when Jason
Goes to Hell it's no longer Jason that's
that's kind of like the cut off point
for me like uh you can still watch him
and be entertained but I mean it's not
even Jason in that movie really it's his
heart going into different people and
you don't see him you don't see him till
the end that is what was great about 80
franchise horror movies because you got
to see him go to these crazy lengths
like I wanted to see more horror icons
go to New York for example or Jason Goes
to Manhattan Jason took Manhattan but
really let's be honest he he took a boat
in that movie and then at the very Andy
takes manham but it's still it's still
absolutely entertaining it's like the
lost world and and and look let I will
give you all the proof you need that
Jason can absolutely destroy Rocky
because when Jason Takes Manhattan he
fights a boxer on top of roof and knocks
his head off just
like you know what Rocky did he beat
Hulk Hogan and Mr T in the same movie
the movie uh he didn't beat Hulk Hogan
he beat thunder lips let's be let's be
fair here's the big thing about your
guys' movies though in each one of your
movies you're really getting the same
thing yes different shots but the same
thing a underdog in a boxing match we're
not Zack Schneider movie uh well the the
one good Zack Snider movie in my opinion
but see with with my zombie movies here
each zombie movie is a different take on
the same event it's a different point of
view it's showing off different uh
sociolog different people defending
their lives against zombies yes yes but
uh in a in a worldwide catastrophe and
how it affects everyone and how we like
you have a commentary on uh consumerism
you have in Night of Living Dead you
have at the time this was uh you had a
strong female and a strong black lead
that was like unheard but see that's the
point like a a movie marathon you're
going to need to turn your brain off
sometimes and you don't need like all
these deep messages and stuff you you're
you're in this for the long
run you might doze off sometimes but
you're not going to miss out what happen
you w up oh there's Jason murdering
somebody again awesome Jason went to
outer space for Christ's sakes and he
destroyed an
entire and well let's real quick back
back to Rocky okay not only did you know
Rocky win best picture which is the only
Oscar winner of a lot um that doesn't
matter he also innovated the Montage
which is very important tool they and
they you know there was an evolution
they do in every movie no and sometimes
three movies but it had the balls to do
three montages in one movie in Rocky 4
oh with the best music to back up those
montages I will say yeah Survivor the
orchestra way out the Rocky album is my
second favorite album of all time I'm
sorry the rocky story is my favorite
album of all time yeah uh 36 mafia in
Rocky baloa which is I like that song
look they are great stories you can
watch them with your family it's
Christmas time that's when you want to
watch it can you each give me the log
line so what I'm in for if I were to sit
and watch let's pick the four let's pick
four of them right in a row let's say
cuz you have four of them yeah I guess
you have five of them I you go six
quickly just give me the the log line
rocky one Rocky just give I don't go do
it quick yeah what what's my adventure
going to be when I sit to watch this bit
the underdog gets the chance of Lifetime
two the underdog wins three the underdog
runs on the beach and then races Apollo
four the underdog defeats communism five
tommy gun or rocky bboa you could yeah
Rocky bboa the underdog shows off that
he is the true champion of the world
Jovin rock me through your your uh
Marathon uh not a living dead how the uh
how it all started um uh you have uh
Dawn of the Dead is how we try to
survive um then you have uh what was the
other the four di um Day of the Dead how
America tries to win against the zombies
then you have diary of the Dead how you
would actually survive in the zombie
apocalypse and then finally how we will
settle and live amongst the zombies
isn't that all just
surviving yeah you felt like you were
confusing yourself a little bit a few
times it a lot of different of the day
Roger walk me through five of this
Marathon all right uh part one mother
avenges the wrongful death of her son uh
part two uh the son comes back to avenge
the mother's death part four crisp and
Glover dances and part eight we see
America destroyed as a boxer gets his
head knocked off by a zombie killing
Jason Vorhees I watch that Shakespeare
play it's not all right I got to call it
and I got to give it to Roger I think
there's just fun about that and there's
so much variety that you can kind of
pick your chooses whereas I just I think
you you pick too many different from
different remakes and things so that's
where you I was I was trying to help you
there and I don't know Rocky I love
Rocky one I love but I don't know it
starts just he has a robot Butler just
do it doesn't uh if I'm going to go
silly I I think Friday the 13th takes it
to the to the funner extent Roger Kudos
thank you you're on the board you know
how silly it is when they're running on
the beach I mean I love Ro you can't
compare that chrisp and cover Dance I
mean it really is one of the best uh
moment he what what's great about that
dance is he was actually dancing to some
completely other music uh but they
played like this weird so it's just a
bad movie uh of course it's a bad movie
It's a Wonderful is it a bad bad movie
is it a bad good movie it's a good bad m
round
four all right so since Jovin you're
with smos games you're a gamer I assume
you like video games been doing that for
a very long time now you like to talk
about them a lot uh they're one of my
favorite things don't talk about them on
first dates most of the time don't take
first dates to closer the movie too well
we thought since you're here it might be
fitting to ask a question we've had a
lot of people ask us uh Abraham deos
sorry if I said that wrong on YouTube
YouTube comments we also read those too
uh what video game should be made into a
movie lot to choose from all through the
eras of video games I want to hear what
is going to be the coolest video game
that's not been done yet that we should
be having Hollywood make immediately and
Jo show we got to start with you yeah
now this one's pretty simple like
obviously you have like the AAA titles
that you're like oh my God make a Halo
movie or make a Legend of Zelda movie
okay no the the smart thing is stay away
from those movies cuz we've gone through
that Adventure we have been um the uh we
we've been link We he doesn't talk that
doesn't make a good movie no one will
like how it how it becomes uh whereas a
movie like Mass Effect wait sorry I
don't even there can't be a good Zelda
movie really there can't be well because
no one you won't be able to make
everyone happy you have a main
protagonist who doesn't speak you to go
through an entire story with having a
character that doesn't speak you don't
think they'd adjust that yeah probably
did did it work for the cartoon did it
work for the cartoon what car I I always
didn't like that cartoon I always
preferred the Mario well that's cuz the
Mario Brothers had the event with swing
your arms from side to side I mean
that's that's going to overtake link of
course could sorry sub maybe we'll save
that for another episode but anyway keep
going on mass you have to you have to
choose a game that has a huge backstory
has a huge lore something that hasn't
even really been touched in the game
itself which is Mass Effect now you
don't want to go with the shepherd
storyline because you are Shephard the
way I played Shephard is definitely the
way uh is different than the way you
guys would have played uh Shephard so
you want to have something like the
first Contact Wars now this just concept
alone when you have Earth finding out
that they can travel through the Galaxy
and coming across aliens that are
already fighting for for space now
America having that we can conquer
everything mentality it's like no we're
in the fight now we can take over but
they're like the like the underdog in
the battle being able to find their
place in this Galactic Senate if you
will uh of like a hierarchy of of
intelligence and and dominion and and
just like wait the minions are in it no
the minion but we can put the minions in
it cuz they make any movie fantastic a
movie they will Roger what's your video
game movie uh my video game movie is the
secret of Monkey Island um this was an
adventure game by Lucas Arts uh uh and
it was basically the first time we ever
saw comedy in a video game it has
incredible writing by Ron Gilbert it is
just absolutely hilarious it's about a
wannabe pirate who's just basically
trying his best to become one and uh you
know solve these Mysteries and along the
way you know he he meets all kinds of
hilarious characters guy with two hook
hands meat hands uh he he meets Stanley
the uh the used car salesman the used
boat salesman and this use like crazy
moving arms and uh very fast talking um
it also introduced uh the ghost pirate
lechu which is great and uh Pirates of
the Caribbean basically stole a lot from
Monkey Island uh is what I've heard and
uh they they've always kind of hoped
that they could eventually get a a a
Monkey Island movie made because the
comedy is so much better in those films
and uh uh I in those games but uh it
also introduced the the idea of insult
sword fighting which I absolutely love
uh as guy brush is training to uh become
a pirate he they they have these sword
fights but they don't actually hit each
other they use insults and whoever uses
the better insult wins the battle and uh
I just think all this stuff like us yeah
that wasn't that wasn't the first video
game with with comedy remember avoid the
Noid in the Nintendo what about Leisure
Suit Larry yeah this was say back back
in those days it was from the same
Sierra Lucas arts arts days but this was
known as like the funniest game made
back then it was just absolutely
incredible what's your choice uh
capcom's final fight a story about a 300
lb ripped mayor played by Dave Batista
uh who has to rescue his kidnapped
daughter would you have the rock PL he
just said Dave batia Dave batia uh I'm
surprised and the girlfriend's boyfriend
played by Chris Hemsworth who's also a
rip karate dude and Tony jaw as playing
guy it's just another dude who can beat
the [__] out of people and all the movie
is is kind of like uh the raid where
it's just one street after another of
them beating the hell out of Street
punks and just kicking ass John
Carpenter directs and just like take the
fight the sides scrolling fight game and
put it to movie where they're just
beating the hell out of people all right
I gotta be honest Nick gave me a really
good pitch I you guys need to give me a
good pitch so cast it who's directing it
what's the what how is it going to look
uh 25 uh like
otherwise Nick's going to keep talking
what's one of you great Bautista does a
spinning pile driver and just breaks
some dude's neck and then uh let's see
you ready Jo St let's go with Stacy keer
and anything yeah I'm gon oh never mind
I thought you said Stacy keer all right
let's go on to something that matters uh
JJ Abrams directing uh the the Mass
Effect movie this man knows space he
knows Adventure he knows game sell me on
this uh this this the story and the
character and who's going to be the
character Humanity his now moved past
Earth finding themselves in the middle
of a Galactic Civil War ooh sound
familiar did that work once in history
guess what it can happen again this time
humans versus Aliens versus even more
aliens lasers all over the place who
plays the main guy who cares there's
aliens and lasers and conquering over
planets yeah Phantom Menace you're yeah
is it like Phantom Menace how is it not
like Phantom Menace um better acting
better story um no Lucas sounds like
Lucas mov right pitch me your movie um I
I would like to see the Cohen Brothers
uh direct secret of Monkey Island I I
think it would be what what what's it
sound like what's it um uh I'm trying to
think who who would be a good good uh uh
person to play guy brush uh possibly
will F will frell actually uh I could
see him uh pulling off that role really
well because he was also great in movies
like Stranger Than Fiction I don't know
the role tell me so will frell doing
what he is Guy brush threw this wannabe
pirate who who who thinks he's great but
just fumbles a lot uh it's kind of like
him in Step Brothers if you if you
appreciate Step Brothers uh that kind of
a movie um you lost me is going to be
wearing Dockers since he's a mayor and a
leather strap on his chest shirtless
just beating the hell out of punk
kids also Tony jaw's there just kicking
the [__] out of me but there's no story
oh yeah it is rescuing the
kidnapped so you're phant of Menace and
you're basically the Warriors yeah yeah
no thank you the I'm it's like the
Warriors don't you're helping them then
no I like I like the Warriors but I
Warriors is like is just like Mad Max
that's a movie that I actually would I
think I think could be
REM is is that no it's not no is
really tagers leather strap beating
people with pipes pirates of the caraban
is about a drunk basically who who's
going around all he only oroom who's
learning to become a pirate to save
here's my here's my problem yours just
sounds like Star Wars tell me why it's
not Star Wars yours sounds like Land of
the Lost a little bit which is making me
a little less exciting will Ferell
exploring around an island I don't know
so which was terrible and mine's about a
300 pound may yours is just I've seen it
before with the what how is it not give
me a how is it different than the raid
which I just I'd rather just watch the
Raid than Chris hemor trying to do the
raid how how so why one last shot here
quickly so uh everyone loves a good
Underdog movie now we're taking the
Underdog Story moving it to a more
Galactic level you take humans who who
have now Skywalker yes who' have now
found their way into outer space and
find that there's life out there there's
technology beyond their own being able
to adapt it and utilize it to now make
their place in the history that is outer
space against other aliens who are
fighting amongst themselves now for them
to join the fight and say no hey this is
our space as well we will not let you
take over our space it's the underdog
level on on a a level that we can't even
fathom because it's it's out of space
you have so much more that can be is it
guarding the Galaxy in tone with comedy
or is it a little bit more serious it's
a little more it's a little more serious
but then you you get those little those
little like nods to the camera like oh
that was a funny smart moment I like
that it's okay okay I I can visualize it
Roger your turn best way I can explain
monk Allen is think of a guy who is
completely unqualified being thrown into
a situation he has real no control over
it's Big Trouble in Little China but
Pirates and that is awesome and I want
to see that movie okay
Nick imagine the guys from predator in a
DI hard situation while the Warriors is
happening Warriors yeah and then they
have to take on bad guys on bad guys to
rescue hager's daughter and it will we
have I just love that nobody born after
1990 well that what talking about Deon
will uh secret of Monkey Island was
re-released not too long ago as a
special edition uh that they completely
redid the artwork for all right I'm
giving I said I'm going off your pitches
and there's two of them I want to see so
that's how I'm going to base my points
the system I kind of want to see that
one that one sounds kind of fun and I
kind of want to see Nick's so I'm going
to give Nick and Ro sorry not
Roger I'm on the board baby I'm on the
board all right Nick has way too many
points in the show we got to Breeze
through some more round five the new
Annie reboot is opening this weekend
just Annie we're all excited for Annie
right guys did you get your tickets hey
if Korea was saying we can go to Andy I
would go see Annie right now so uh hot
shadow on Twitter asks hot Shadow that's
a good one what does that mean is that a
game reference or is he trying to be
smooth Sil he a radio DJ uh hot Shadow
coming at you from 96.5 best movie
musical from hot Shadow uh what's the
best movie musical now I want to we I
know what they're going to say in
advance because we prepare for the show
and I I'm want to make it clear I want
the best movie with original music it
doesn't have to be
Bradway I've warned you all some of them
made some so I I've given them the time
reconsider where my bias is going to go
uh that said let's go through it Roger
best movie musical movie with music
Original singing music the the best
movie musical uh is Popeye and the this
is a classic they actually built an
entire town for this and it still stands
today it it's in uh Malta and uh it's
called poey Village they actually built
this entire thing and uh uh the music in
it is wonderful uh it's it's got these
hilarious songs like like blo Bluto just
talking about how he's beating the crap
out of everybody I mean I'm mean I'm
mean you know what I mean and uh you you
have uh Ray walon uh as popey's father
uh just you know bitching about kids and
about how you know you get them a lot of
toys and what do they give you they give
you a lot of noise it's great uh and you
also have just these amazing the the
amazing sets all these wonderful
characters what song do I know from that
movie cuz none of those are I'm pop by
the Sailor Man oh that doesn't really is
there a origal song from I don't
remember Shel Dall you know it from a
different movie probably punch Junk Love
Oh yes the sh yep okay and he's large
that's right I do remember no I remember
the movie it's been a while yeah it's
it's it's not easy to watch these days
uh Nick all right my favorite movie
musical is important for two reasons and
a very one special reason uh the first
one is it features uh William Daniels Mr
feny from Boy Meets World what movie is
are we talking about
1776 about the the musical about the
Congressional hearing
about the year yeah about them
historically accurate too they were
singing the entire time about the
Declaration of Independence it stars uh
William Daniels Mr FY for John Adams and
also when it came out in 17 1972 And
when Richard Nixon's son early cut of
the movie he made them he forced them to
cut a scene from the movie because he
deemed it it was too gay so this musical
sounds like some North Korea would do
yeah I know exactly it's very pertinent
to the situation and uh it feels like
and they did because tricky Dick had
some issues with you know being
uncomfortable with it and it was man
you're really playing to our
audience yeah we just keep going we keep
going further back in time yeah I mean I
don't even I don't know anything you're
talking about let's go to Joven Shire
see I'm a man of the people the the the
the person that asked this question
asked what is the favorite musical uh so
you have to go with a musical and I'm
going to say rent now you asked what is
the best movie with original music all
right all right Empire Strikes Back has
original music in it you said nothing
about singing
lyrics at the at the presentation of the
question uh the question was what is the
best musical uh rent did a great job
adapting a three-hour long musical play
me for theater with an intermission and
uh translated it very well to the big
screen now in this yes you not some of
the dialogue was spoken not necessarily
sung and that worked for the audience
the audience uh now was introduced uh
this movie was introduced to an audience
that maybe didn't see rent before so now
it was easier to take in because it
wasn't just 2 hours of just singing it
was a a great telling of a specific time
a specific generation and it the songs
are catchy the songs you still know and
it makes you cry at the end um well to
be more accurate we were posed with the
question what is the best uh movie uh
musical but that was not based on a
Broadway or any actual music look I lost
okay but but but popey Popeye has has
the best it's also the best movie of the
three uh you you see poey uh he he gets
forced to eat the spinach and then this
giant arm comes out from underwater
punches Bluto so hard he actually turns
yellow and goes swimming away like a
coward um you also have an octopus
underwater which I believe was the
octopus how many songs in that movie Dan
can you fact check for me I also there's
a lot I never thought I'd say this I'm
going to stick up for Richard Nixon a
little bit first of all it wasn't when
he saw the movie it was when he saw the
production of the musical at the White
House and I can't find any reference of
him saying that something was too gay
look up cool considerate yeah they said
that he they said that he thought it was
a criticism of the presidency and the
criticism government I don't
see I can't believe I'm say I'm G to
stick up for Richard Nixon a little bit
here say I can't find any evidence of
too many Politics the show looking at
popey versus rent uh if you're looking
at the best of something like who would
have thought that fight would that's the
thumnail that's the thumbnail the music
of our friend I don't think that'll be
our thumbnail you have to look at at the
best like what stands uh the test of
time popey though good movie uh you
can't remember any songs from it outside
of the main theme song that only us
absolutely remember so many no Li King
Li King is the best yeah no one picked
that or or South Park Singing in the
Rain or any of the
classic no I'm just talking about a
movie that that I grew up on and I mean
you have Robin Williams who was perfect
as popey and he really was perfect it's
it's a fun story it's a weird it's a
weird it is a weird movie and I don't
remember M I'd go South Park
easily you got the point but just don't
remember the music and then I don't
think rent was a good adaptation I think
the Broadway musical was good the movie
wasn't that good so I'm I can't give
anyone a point story singing in the r
can't give give me give me the point
I've made the best argument here for the
best I had a good ARG I actually picked
a musical that's
so you be honest which
three that's all I'm saying very
begrudgingly no no clapping Nola
clapping Bo play that American music
again play that inspirational want the
boo right now guys what's our favorite
Marvel movie that's for all three of you
that was a terrible fight hey you guys
asked the question it's not our all frog
I clarified several times and that was a
we're getting an all Marvel movie next
to our guns you never you you told them
they were terrible answers and they're
like yeah they are and I Tri to let's
have this debate again next year when I
can choose anak Kendrick's the last five
years I would have taken Pitch Perfect
over any
those you should have joined the debate
over that anyway moving on travesty all
right all right way better interesting
fight coming in from mat I cannot I'm
sorry dude that's a really hard name to
say matuso s I can't do
it apologize it's on the screen Kudos do
you sir I don't not want to butcher your
name not laughing at your name I'm but
laughing at myself I can't believe I
don't know how to do that uh my phone
move best Ian McKellen movie um what do
we think guys Hobbit franchise just
wrapped up uh he's been several
franchises uh what's the best movie
we're not talking character or franchise
what's his best movie nick uh app pupil
uh bride siger's app pupil came out in
1998 where he actually plays a uh Nazi
who's now hiding in America
under a different Alias his real name is
Kurt um and it's just it's him and Brad
Renfro and it's a really creepy
character study and it's like this just
two guys playing mind games with each
other and it's it's brilliant and it's
the movie that kind of like reput him on
the map I mean God and monsters too but
app pupil was the one that got him
Magneto it was the one that got him Lord
of the Rings and it's what started it's
what put um Ian McKellen Into The Ether
it's what if it didn't if he didn't do
this movie there would be like Sean
connory as Gand off or something
terrible okay uh Josh I'm sorry joov and
Shire um I'm going to go with um the
first X-Men movie now to play a a great
villain you have to bring up a side of
the villain that people can relate to
almost see them as a victim and Eden
McKellen brings like some of the best uh
casting that I've seen in a superhero
movie next to something like Hellboy as
Magneto um he's a Magneto is a character
that you feel for or D
uh Magneto is a character that you feel
for you understand where he's coming
from and you honestly kind of believe in
his in his message just not in the way
that he he perceives it or the way that
he he takes action and to have a villain
that you you love and hate at the same
time is not an easy task and this is
something that Ian McKellen did
perfectly perfectly you see why
Professor X is still Magneto's friend
that's not easy to do yeah Roger okay uh
I believe uh Lord of the Rings
Fellowship of the ring uh is by far his
his best work yeah I I agree app pupil
kind of puts him on the map but I I
think Lord of the Rings as Gandalf the
gy is what uh really uh that's that's
his his real big uh uh role uh he he has
said himself that Gandalf the gy is a
lot cooler than uh you know Gandalf the
White because uh he he's more interested
you know he he's having fun with the
hobbits you know he's partying with them
he's smoking uh he's in bars and
everything and he he's in more danger so
his character is actually more
threatened then and less confident than
than you know Gandalf the the white but
um uh the other thing about it is Ian
McKellen himself has been interviewed
about who would win in a fight between
Gandalf and Magneto and he said Gandalf
hands downn down and he has thousand of
years experience doesn't have any medal
on what's movie fights Josh I'm sorry
and ker would trick both of them into
killing each other and then like you
know wasn't Gods and Monsters really the
movie that put him on the map before app
people I think it's I think it's app
people I really think it's a lot of
people liked him in six de of Separation
that he got a lot of praise for that too
also but like the beyond that I think
it's just both really Gods monsters
monsters at people same year Gods and
Monsters came out but I think the
performance first it was really the and
then when it was for Fellowship
man uh- so God mon in that pupil in 988
X-Men was in 2000 Fellowship was in 2001
wow those are really good three years
yeah no so app people like to me I think
all great performances but the
performance that like he honestly got
robbed in like winning it some awards
was at people that was his best
performance like and while good in those
movies I think also random fact was the
short story that was in the same novel
as Sha Shank Redemption and The Stand
Stephen King yep uh not as good as those
two movies even Kell was doing great
movies before ACT people though you can
argue that this what's put people kicked
open the door and was like Hey I'm this
guy who not best these other movies is
by far it is uh though these other uh
like our movies followed app pupil how
do we know that app pupil is actually
what helped him get these roles like he
had a great
care he said if I wanted Magneto play
him after doing that pupil so here's my
problem right help me because I this is
really tough this is a tough one to
judge they're all great performances
he's a great actor I'm now I am going to
have to change this the question a bit
which is sorry but gandf and Magneto I
just think way too even if take away the
franchise even just a single movie Just
such more iconic characters that so
nuanced and for a character role I think
he brought so much gravitas and weight
to it I'm just I'm being honest I'm
ruling you out for that just fact alone
of trying to then pick somebody out of
this mess you don't want an app pup
thumbnail app pupil it was fine but I
also just didn't think it was that great
a film he was good in it I think it's
great but I can't compared to his role
as Gandalf and his role as Magneto I
just think they both so I apologize I'm
just being clear that's why but it was a
good good fair fight so now I'm I'm I'm
feel free to know I'll invite you to
chime in here if you'd like Magneto yes
my scoff is where I do think is an
interesting battle here and I think you
said something really great of it's he
did where's there was that Nuance of he
played the villain and the friend which
I do think right now is is the best
point but I want to give you some time
to fight that what was the Nuance in in
for G for for acting just that
performance the the acting for him is
sacrifice uh he he's he's not only you
know helping trying to help these
Hobbits uh make it away he stands up
against that giant monster and and falls
and and tells them to fly you fools uh
and it's it's also one of his most
quotable roles I mean who hasn't said
You shall not pass I mean that is Ian
McKellen's defining role of his career
said Senator all the time yeah
like see and that's where I'm struggling
is if we go defining role I think you
win if we go best performance it's X-Men
Magneto I'm really wrestling here
because can I point out that melen was
nominated for an Oscar for Fellowship
thank you was Best Supporting Actor now
it's uh I should have run the it is
easier to play a hero than it is a
villain especially a villain that has so
many layers and I think like I mentioned
before trying to pull out that
performance and make you feel for a
villain is not something that's that's
easy to do playing Gandalf it's easy
like he's the the mentor to this
Fellowship um I think you're
discrediting the writers by by saying
that I mean if if you have good writing
you can play an excellent and you have a
good actor you can play an excellent
hero that people can feel forward same
for an excellent bad guy that uh people
can I'm going hate for this but I mean
well I'm I'm sorry I'm playing my cards
a little bit too much but I'm looking at
the question again best Ian McKellen
movie it's not performance it's best in
Movie Lord of the Rings Fellowship of
the Ring Fellowship of the Ring versus
X-Men so I'm going to upset Somebody by
picking one of these which movies better
but and I'm going to say it I thought
Fellowship was kind of boring it got
better with retur of the king and to
hour and so that's where I'm stuck on
like why why was that one why was that
the best movie over X-Men which I do
think helped Define superhero movies in
a way that has the better G of
performance uh but bestan Mallen movie
is what's on here and I'm trying to get
some sort of it's best McKellen movie uh
he he said it himself that's his
favorite movie uh it it's also um uh
this is the one that sets up the entire
story uh this
this Trilogy the trilogy is amazing as a
movie I found that one to be not as as
fulfilling I had to wait two years to
see where it went as a standalone movie
I had a problem with Fellowship is what
I meant by that here's the thing here's
the thing and this is me coming from it
Fellowship is a better movie than X-Men
one he does a better performance than
Xmen is the best I agree so that's where
I'm struggling so I got movie fact
Checker is his best movie or best Ian
McKellen performance I I what do you
think what what's the wording of the
question best Ian McKellen movie is not
the performance
and wait a second that is a very strong
ensemble cast is that an Ian mcken movie
both they both are well it's it's you
have you're sharing now like nine
different very important roles where in
X-Men you're looking at three different
he has more on his shoulders than this
than he does
in Awards hold on Awards and and fandom
aside why is fell one last chance reach
you why is fellowship the best movie and
then I'm going to ask you why is Xmen a
better movie uh why why Fellowship is a
better movie Fellowship as a standalone
film is better than X-Men as a
standalone film it it's just this
incredible epic adventure it it it sets
it does set the tone for everything but
as as an individual movie you you see
these Hobbits uh just tasked with this
in incredible uh uh responsibility that
they have to go out and and uh take care
of Gandalf kind of pulls them all
together you have all you uh get to meet
all the elves you have them going in
into the mountains uh uh against you
have the other wizard
I mean there's just there's so much
complexity to this movie and it is an
incredible adventure and it does end
with Gandalf being sacrificed and and
you are left wondering what happened to
him J that's it uh in Lord of the Rings
you uh for a good story you need a
beginning middle and end no one says hey
my favorite Lord of the Rings movie was
fellowship with the ring it's two towers
or uh Jovin my favorite Lord of the
Rings movie was fellowship with the ring
okay I'm in the wrong audience then mine
wasn't but three against two so you have
uh fellowship with the ring is just the
of a story whereas the first X-Men has
um a beginning a middle and an end and
let's look at just one big setup of the
let him let him finish now even if when
you look at the um oh was it the second
movie or was it the first movie um which
one did it you just feel for I that's
what I'm here for so you you um you feel
for uh the different characters you
you're on more of an adventure whereas
fellowship with the ring it's it's one
of three it is it cannot be seen by
itself X-Men is one of three as well and
feel for the characters you absolutely
feel for the characters I'm sorry I'm
going to say violence for you but I'm
about to punch you but look look at
least in X-Men yes there's a trilogy but
you have three separate stories you have
one one overarching story he's just
asking one one story here uh SE
movies if you if you sit down and you
watch Fellowship of the Ring okay now I
need to see Towers now I need to see
King see X-Men and stop after the first
one be like that was a great story all
right all right I'll agree with you but
I think Roger takes the point it was
very close it was a good one but I do
think it just it's a combination of it
is they're both probably equally good
movies Ian the weird thing is the weird
thing is better performance in X-Men
Fellowship is a better movie he even got
tat
AR more iconic McKellen him and the cast
they all
Gotto Roger won the fight was really
about the fight you got a little
confused on which movie was which so
that was where I wavered and Roger takes
it now the point has been given I I do
agree one of the is a better movie than
next I have a minor corre and now now
I'm going to uh kill
Nick Roger and Nick are tied at 33 and
has
one I have a minor correction you got
your Stephen King stands a little mixed
up you said that same no as the stand it
was the same stand by stand I knew that
Sor I know you knew that I Stand By Me
good mov Stand By Me and sha shank are
in that for it's what's it called the uh
it's it's Rita Haworth and sha Shank
Redemption at people the body which is
Stand By Me and then there's one called
the breathing method which has actually
never been
AAP played ver and all right we we got
to wrap these up we don't time here uh
rumors came out uh rumors came out that
uh this week uh that
um it's too late for Spider-Man to be in
Civil War uh but he might be an Infinity
War because we we we've heard through
the Great Vine uh through news sources
that got the sources legally but uh
we've heard that Sony is try in talks
with Marvel we're speculating now if
they did that who would we want to play
Spider-Man if the rights were sorry
thank you round seven uh that was a
terrible setup thank you J uh round
seven fight seven who should uh play
Spider-Man if the rights revert back to
Marvel and they do hit the reset button
and decide to start it over who do we
think should it be Jovin we're starting
with you um I think actually uh I want
to stick with Andrew Garfield I I do
think he was kind of robbed in the
Amazing Spider-Man movies because of bad
writing he plays a great socially
awkward nerd that though maybe
good-looking still like has a hard time
like getting those sentences out but
then can play the opposite side of the
coin as Spider-Man and have this new
confidence and wittiness about him that
that's that that's like the hero within
uh I think that he brings a lot to the
table and is we never really got to see
the true potential uh of Andrew Garfield
in a role of Peter Parker and Spider-Man
because of bad writing Roger uh I I
don't think Andrew Garfield uh is the
right role for it because he do he does
look too much like a model and
Spider-Man should be like this awkward
nerdy kind of a guy I I I that's what I
want I thought Toby was a much better uh
Peter Parker um but I I I think uh you
want someone who's awkward but also has
good comedic timing I think that's
really important and I that's why I
would pick someone like Adam Scott and I
I know I know it's an unusual I know
it's un but he still looks young he does
and um he looks like a young 35 but my
my answer is two parts uh I I I think
Adam Scott would be perfect for Peter
Parker but I also think that the rock
would be the best for Spider-Man in the
costume wait The Rock The Rock are we
serious what it's got a point how is how
would their B is this face off no no my
real answer is my real answer is Tony
jaw uh I wanted to see him uh be
actually he's he's an incredible martial
artist I mean so why doesn't Tony JIS do
it all what's with his body switch is
that unfair to Tony J hey dude just put
this mask on and do stuff but we're
going to put Al Scot okay let me hold on
hold on no no uh first off uh he doesn't
speak the the best English as I recall
uh on top of that he's not known you
know for acting he's he's known for his
martial arts uh skills and you know I I
wouldn't be surprised if uh I mean I
don't know the facts on this maybe you
can check if there have been stunt guys
in the Spider-Man costume for certain
scenes in the previous movies I assume
funny enough Tony J is going to be in
Furious 7 interesting okay yeah well
that doesn't make me want to see Fu 7
Nick who would you I'll talk Toth Kore R
of Peter Parker we've seen five movies
with Peter Parker let's go with the
ultimate Spider-Man's Miles Morales and
the perfect person to play him is uh
sorry I'm sorry Donald Glover Donald
Glover is funny uh he can do drama he's
got Charisma he's like like this is like
this perfect role for like a young Will
Smith and he could play a different
Spider-Man Miles not Jaden Smith thank
you not Jaden Smith no no but like no I
think this would be perfect I think he
would fit in better with Miles morales's
character would fit in much more in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe since it's so
based on on the more of the Ultimate
Comics uh version I just think that
would be better he'd be funnier Andrew
Garfield's had two movies your movie
your idea is insane um like I don't want
to see a 40-year-old Adam Scott and a
guy who looks nothing like him playing
Spider-Man I just also think it's kind
of offensive to Tony jaw like hey just
only put the mask
well Ray Park was uh the Headless
Horseman and then turned into um f you
you we've seen so much Peter Parker we
need to give him a break so if they're
going to put Spider-Man in let's do
something up let's shake it up let's do
a different perspective of Spider-Man
and and I think like you could see from
like what's it like being a kid living
in New York City and the perspective of
it young 20 I mean great and and not be
an emo kid I think that would be but the
emo kid that that wasn't uh his
portrayal of it that was a uh Andrew
Garfield that was the talking about Toby
mgu too either yeah the whole Peter
Parker can I challenge you are you
really just not into that idea I I I do
like some ideas especially because the
Cinematic Universe does have uh is more
leaning towards the universal did you
like the Spider-Man movies did uh with
the first one and the second onei first
oh not Garfield Garfield no the second
one was one of the worst superhero
movies I think written is it Nick shut
up I'm trying is it hard for you to
really separate then and just say oh
Andrew Garfield's now in and they were
supposed to just ignore the first two
movies you're okay that it's possible to
look in like look past the the writing
as I keep going to Andrew Garfield was
able to portray a socially awkward nerd
that though handsome it is very like I'm
not even disp I'm actually not hug but I
I get your argument and Garfield's fine
but I'm talking about now really step
away from it is that really right then
to now reset Spider-Man with the same
actor when he's done
recently I I love Toby Maguire but I
wouldn't want him back at Spider-Man
this is why it works is because Marvel
in those rumors has said that it won't
be an origin story we aren't going to be
doing the romances it's going to be like
Spider-Man's been around for a while so
it makes sense to did that stupid plot
line in our Marvel Universe really
you're okay with that no you know look
dude I actually like Garfield in it I
think he's better than Maguire but I and
I've argued that before I just think
start over you don't need to do an
origin story and throw in something
different throw something different
Point again dang it dang
it my God makes sense to have Garfield
and I apologize for doing this thing
that was Johnny manelis and I apologize
but I I really don't think uh to just to
go back to Tony jar real quick I don't
think that would insulting I mean he
deserves he deserves giant look at
actors like um but he's all CGI he don't
really do fight but that's what I'm
saying like in a reboot of Spider-Man I
want to see him doing Tony Jaws fighting
moves some there are some actors that
get more um all right I killed it I
sorry blame me I I didn't I didn't care
for the Tony SC Scott Tony fine you
don't have to like the Adam Scott round
eight round eight now Nick is it just to
make the tension here Nick's up a point
right Dan I'm correct here and then
Roger's down a point so you're want if
you do this we have to go to TI Breer
jov and unless you uh really pull Mira
Christmas miracle with some amazing
battle
here let's keep going it's always a
tough in the first time you're you've
done great doing great um I'm going to
invite you back don't worry got any
point I think you've done way better
than Nick for for the record so but
everyone do as always the last one is a
cue to our honest trailer um and uh next
uh week's honest trailer uh is a uh what
did we write here so I say screw uh it's
a property about teenagers with weapons
that was produced by Michael B I wonder
what that is so Michael Bay didn't
direct this movie but he produced this
movie and that UPS this question that we
thought might be fun as everyone hates
on Bay right everyone says he shouldn't
do anything what franchise should
Michael Bay produce which one would we
actually like him to take over uh that's
our fight which I think could be fun
let's see what Roger says I think
Michael Bay should take on Rocky um I
want to see I mean Rocky has already
gone up against some pretty insane odds
uh uh you know he's he's had to fight Mr
T is he going to go up against
Transformers in your version will he
knock the head off of a transformer
here's the thing uh think about it uh
Rocky Rocky's face you know Ivon Drago
who was pretty much the toughest
character I think he he's fought in all
the movies so so now now you need
someone whose punches cause explosions
and if you have that if you have Rocky
fighting somebody who single punches can
explode somebody but Rocky is made out
of iron as Ivan Drago has said before if
Rocky's going against this guy I think
that'll be an amazing fight Dan didn't
Hugh Jackman make this movie with
battling robots no real also to point
out that Rocky uh Sylvester Sone still
controls the rocky franchise they're
doing Creed which sounds awesome so he's
not letting that you do you like the cre
have you heard about the Creed reboot no
I actually hadn't heard Michael B
Jordan's playing Apollo's like grandson
and Rocky's going to train him man
Michael B Jordan all over the place I'm
kind of into that I like no Michael B
Jordan but do you want Michael B to
produce
that all right it's fair it's it's not
over yet Nick okay the the Don Simpson
and brookheimer made an amazing movie
with Tony Scott called Top Gun with Tom
Cruz the only and we need to make
unfortunately Tony Scott died but we
need to maybe see a Top Gun movie in
this lifetime I think we need to see Tom
Cruz uh step into the instructor and and
and and pilot this next Generation like
Chris PR as a badass pilot and Brook I'm
sorry Michael B is the perfect person to
take what Don Simpson and brookheimer
created and then carry it to the next
level in the new generation that's why I
want Michael Bay to produce a series of
Top Gun movies that has nothing to do
with China Top Gun should never be
remade because because it it's it's the
perfect comedy it is it's not a comedy
it's oh it is absolutely a comedy if
you've watched that volleyball scene
that's all you need to know it's a
comedy and you have you have ican
chomping his teeth at him as a response
that's a respon
that's how you win a debate you know how
sexy Michael B's volleyball scene will
be actually I'd love to see sexy scene
problem Chris Hemsworth as sexy Goose
see that's the thing he'll just have
upskirt shots of Megan Fox in his
version is that bad is that bad yes
because you want to see the hilarious
unintentional homosexuality of the
original Top Gun has Michael B has such
a stigma about him and and a Top Gun is
is a favorite movie for so many people
if someone saw Bill and saw oh Michael
baay is going to do top movie so Jo
what's your selection uh since I'm not
really in this game I'm going to I'm
going to have some fun with this I think
we need to keep Michael Bay in his own
little world that he's already created
let him have a Transformers movie until
like let's do a reboot of the
Transformers let's keep him with the
Transformers but just keep the people
out of it uh I just found out today that
um Mark Wahlberg will be in Transformers
5 already a big mistake no more people
so you're playing doing Michael Bay
Transformers the movie like in the
planet Cybertron yes just all giant uh
robots fighting each other kicking each
other's ass that have all the explosions
because we love what makes a Michael Bay
movie we love uh hot women and
over-the-top explosions we don't like
his dialogue we don't need that dialogue
giant robots punching each other
shooting each other explosions on
cyberon you got the power see that's
that's the movie I want the original
Transformers but we're not going to get
that Michael B has the power let him do
it because they're going to look like
just these shards of metal that are all
like mangled together won't resemble the
Transformers and it will not have Weird
Al yanic on the soundtrack I guarantee
you that and that's a shame he just dare
to be stupid You've Got The Touch I mean
that's that's the Transformers movie we
want the classic wow okay so your
argument is that you say leave him there
but also let him relaunch it again is
that a reason your reason because you
don't want him to touch anything else
he's not a good uh uh director when it
comes to director produce when it comes
to dialogue and and and characters and
and and humans give him robots can I be
honest I don't like any of these choices
that much to be does anyone want to
throw out a second
idea second idea for a Micha movie
quickly I want keep doing Bad Boys 3
that's what I want him to
concentrate the original Bad Boys with
Shawn Penn is the best bad I want to see
I want to see Bad Boys 3 with the rock
Will Smith and Martin Lawrence that
would be the best movie ever Michael
produces the Punisher boom The Punisher
produced by Michael do lungren did the
best Punisher we already all know that
all right one last chance Rogers and
another one you can think of that might
be more fitting for Michael Bay take
take a second it's okay all right all
right let me let me think you know how
this show Works don't go some obscure
weird 8s heart no I'm not going he's
done a lot of
those rat all right all right Michael
Bay does predator we we know we know he
can do the science fiction stuff you
want to bring back a predator without
Arnold without without all this stuff
have him introduce an entirely different
looking Predator it'll be something
crazy and robotic I'm sure and all but
it'll be special effects destroying
everything hold on hold on whoa whoa
whoa who destroy hold on tell me
more it's like I am intrigued sir
Predator 2 Predator versus I think it's
IMM Predator versus aliens and that was
awful for forget Humanity they they are
in outer space in their own Predator
world all predators going against
themselves this is like the
predator
Transformers on their own Planet
the fighting the cocaine Fortress are
they fighting the Predators yes
yes they've joined forces for one
argument God I would watch Will Smith
and Martin Lawrence vers I got to give R
the point Thank you wow I have all those
choices that sounds fun but and you know
what it does that makes it high and
we're out of time so we have to do a
speed round which to me can we just
fight we're going to do it
really we have to keep this quick cuz we
got to wrap this up so I'm giving you
you can listen sorry Jovin good good
battle got they have some
history I don't want to give we have
five quick sorry we have five quick
battles you got to give me your quick
answers each of you going to get one and
it's not much fighting it's really got
to be on the quick you does that make
sense I'm going to give you a question
you're going to go quickly and I'm it's
lightning round just like one word I may
do a followup but it's going to be one
quick thing and maybe a three line a
three word explanation Dan anything to
throw in before we go
I going to say I didn't want to give
Nick unfair Advantage but the president
agrees with him on the interview he just
said it was a mistake to pull it so
Obama wow Mundy finally they said
something it's about time all right we
ready for Speed round do we have any
like exciting music if you find if you
do go for it Dan sorry hold on you want
me to sing
I no don't do that all right here we go
round one on our speed round all right
could two Batman take out a
wolverine yes one one Batman could take
out a wolverine absolutely yeah yes well
you he makes a point one could I think
he's right Roger gets the point Thank
You O Come on Nick who's the best movie
Archer hold on legless Katniss Susan
from Narnia or roye or the girl from
Brave I'll throw her in too best movie
Archer Katniss uh legalist see he killed
an elephant and uh a ton of people
revolutionary hero and really hot I got
to go legalist man that's two for Roger
you had me really hot oh Nick
but it's about archery not aboutness
Rick yeah Rick Moranis or Steve
Gutenberg I said it first he did he did
we agree it's the best question of all
time yeah that that was a good one but
the goo man ready ready White House Down
or Olympus Has Fallen white down Olympus
Has
Fallen you're both wow this is it those
movies were great this the last
one
I love this best Adam sailor film oh God
happy
gor um there's only one right answer man
pun drunk love that's not it Billy
Madison no it's water boy guys come on
go get out our right answer was said
punch drunk love I'm going to go
with Happy Gilmore oh my
God ladies gentl you saw here
bu chaos
W wa wa W you're dead you're dead ni
you're de come on well that's a way to
wrap up the year if I've ever seen it
guys tell us who was wrong I Nick never
thought he'd win he just won I can't
believe it that was a very good that
round down the wire that was
intense thanks for watching what did you
guys think what fight do you want to see
next Joven Shire thanks for coming let
me than my
guest you can check us out over at smos
games on YouTube and please leave
comments below saying how you loved all
of my arguments over these guys'
arguments yes please and I please come
back I'm sorry these two clowns uh they
have a lot of experience uh next to him
Roger bar at imri it's IM at Twitter
right I uh m o c k e r y you can know #
Roger was
robbed and that I think I think I just
won the actual fight so so there I win I
win uh and also uh go to IM mo.com iym
mo.com I got new pixel posters oh yeah
his pixel posters are amazing do check
them out dick Fundy fight mondy fight
fight mondy fight at dick Fundy thank
you that was Nick I never thought it
would happen I never but you did it I
know it's been taking a while I want to
remat we're we're having war war as
always if you're listening or watching
you please go check us out on iTunes
subscribe right there as always also
please check out the popcorn talk movie
network uh they are on YouTube Popcorn
Talk network uh and I also want to thank
uh Dan Merl on The Dan cam # danam Dan
how was that crazy that was nuts and I
I'm so looking forward to next week's
show which we've already pre-taped which
the stakes might have just gotten a lot
lower danam were you scared that one of
us was going to get body slammed on you
yes so to be clear we have one more
episode we have one more episode we
pre-taped uh for the holidays you'll see
it next Sunday uh where we do the best
of the Year this Fell's back Will he win
again Hal Rudnick Dan Merl and I'm on
the J I'm on the panelist it's crazy
it's going to be nuts did I do a good
job you'll find out next Sunday always
as always check out Schoo and the
popcorn Talk network youtube.com/
popcorn Talk Network movie Meet the
movie press Marvel news Jedi Alliance
then movie check them out too please
because they have been great supporters
of ours and as always uh tell me at Andy
signor on Twitter what you want to see
or at screen junkies or all of us uh
what you want to see us fight about
thanks so much for watching have awesome
holiday we'll see you next year and
you'll see you pre-tape next week see
you guys
every podcast we put on YouTube comes
with this Kick-Ass graphic listing all
the topics your favorite screen junkies
podcasters are talking about if you
click the topics you can skip around and
choose your own podcast Battle Royale go
ahead try them all if you haven't
already subscribe to screen junkies on
YouTube to join us for future fights or
if you prefer to listen on iTunes click
the logo to download an audio version
lastly please support our friends at the
popcorn Talk network for more awesome
shows